[Music]
Emma is a latina hairdresser a stay at
home orders went into effect and large
parts of the economy shut down she is
among the tens of millions of workers
who have lost their jobs in just a
couple of months a closer look at data
show how that economic pain is
distributed among Americans and it turns
out that job losses during the pandemic
have fallen disproportionately on people
like Emma here's how gender occupation
and race data can help us understand
record unemployment numbers it's
actually unique to this unemployment
crisis that women have been the hardest
hit in previous recessions women tended
to fare better than men men held the
dominant share of jobs in sectors like
manufacturing and construction which
typically bear the brunt of an economic
downturn during the 2009 financial
crisis unemployment among men reached
11.1% compared to a peak of 9% for women
this period also marked the first time
in US history that women outnumbered men
in the workforce since many of them had
occupations and sectors that were more
resilient during a recession like
education or health care economists say
many married women who hadn't been
employed also joined the workforce to
replace or supplement their partners
lost income by 2019 women outnumbered
men in the u.s. paid workforce for the
second time in history
growth in service sector professions
actually allowed women to overtake men
as the dominant share of all non-farm
payrolls that occurred you know at the
end of last year but the pandemic has
now upended that women account for about
77 percent of workers and occupations
that require close personal contact and
can't easily be done remotely which is
you know a lot of those jobs have been
hit by the social distancing measures
and so those are jobs in food
preparation health care support and
personal service for instance the
unemployment rates for both black and
Hispanic women were higher than the
unemployment rate for white women if you
dive a bit deeper into the data you see
that the service sector jobs that can't
be done from home employ more black and
Latinas for many working from home is
not an option people are having to make
very difficult choices between what's
best for their economic well-being and
what's best for their health and public
safety Valerie Wilson is an economist
and director of the race and ethnicity
program at the Economic Policy Institute
she stresses that economic insecurity
isn't the only hurdle Hispanic and black
women face workers of color are in a
very difficult predicament based on
their position in the labor market and
in this economy and society as a whole
status showed that women tend to spend
more time than men with household
responsibilities and childcare making
job search is much harder on top of that
most black and Latinas who work in low
paid jobs are also the sole or primary
breadwinners in their households
according to a women's rights group
Wilson and other economists expect the
road to recovery to be even steeper for
black women and Latinas
I think getting back to work will be
harder for women and women of color in
particular because when we recover the
same jobs that were lost
probably
will not return as quickly so that will
be one factor in a slower recovery in
those communities
[Music]